Y a-t-il des compromis inhérents
incompatibles avec notre paradigme actuel de développement ?
Y a-t-il des synergies permettant d’accélérer le changement ?
Est-ce un programme de populations et planète
qui traite sérieusement les objectifs sociaux et économiques
dans des systèmes de survie terrestre ?
Des citoyens du monde entier ont commencé à reconnaître
les risques environnementaux accrus.
Une planète stable est un préalable
au bien-être humain sur terre.
Un espace fonctionnel sûr dans un système stable doit être défini.
Le concept de limites planétaires avait été présenté
par la communauté scientifique en 2009
pour aborder ce problème.
Le concept est unanimement accepté à travers le monde,
en politique, entreprises et collectivités
comme structure de développement durable
de l’Anthropocène.
Voici les neuf processus environnementaux
qui régulent la stabilité du système terrestre,
permettant un espace opérationnel sûr
et de bonnes chances de garantir le bien-être humain,
la prospérité et l'équité.
Dans la zone jaune, nous entrons dans une zone d'incertitude.
Dans la rouge, il y a probabilité de franchir les points de basculement
qui nous entraînerait définitivement hors de la capacité du système terrestre
de fournir un bien-être social et économique aux humains.
Nous pouvons scientifiquement quantifier les limites
qui permettraient une stabilité terrestre pour l’humanité.
Nous devons aller plus loin
et admettre que les ODD
- si nous voulons vraiment nous les réaliser -
doivent être atteints dans cet espace opérationnel sûr.
Il faut atteindre les ODD dans les limites planétaires.
Même cela n'est pas suffisant.
Nous devons tenir compte que l'atteinte des objectifs
est fixé dans 12 ans.
Ce n'est qu'une étape.
C'est la cible à atteindre pour ensuite
nous lancer vers des transformations
menant à un bel avenir sur Terre pour plus de 9 milliards de concitoyens
dans un système terrestre
C'est une quête.
Afin d'explorer cela, et non seulement avoir des opinions,
les chercheurs se sont réunis avec les meilleurs penseurs et modeleurs
pour développer un nouveau modèle de systèmes complexes et dynamiques,
le modèle Earth-3,
construit sur des modèles datant de 50 ans.
Le voici.
C’est un travail remarquable,
qui comprend des modules climatiques, biosphériques et économiques mondiaux,
des algorithmes, une panoplie de grandes réalisations.
C’est ce qui nous allume, les scientifiques.
(Rires)
N'est-ce pas du beau travail ?
Je passerais bien la soirée à discuter des détails avec vous,
mais je vais vous décevoir.
Je ne peux pas.
Je peux seulement vous assurer
que c’est une première.
Personne auparavant n’a essayé de combiner analytiquement
des ODD et les limites planétaires.
On a repéré des modèles et des tendances convergentes,
nous donnant confiance en notre capacité de projeter
le développent économique,
l’utilisation des ressources (eau, nourriture et énergie),
la poussée démographique, le revenu par habitant
à l’aide de ces lignes cohérentes et systémiques.
C'était notre première solide opportunité pour explorer
la capacité future d'atteindre les ODD dans les limites planétaires
Qu'avons-nous fait ?
Regardez.
Ici, vous avez les données tirées du monde réel,
calibrées de 1970 à 2015 :
100 000 points de données dans le monde,
exploitant les capacités de sept régions,
sélectionnant les ODD.
Voici un exemple de calibration :
ici, vous avez les données des ODD
sur l’éradication de la pauvreté, la santé, l’éducation et l’alimentation.
Ici, dans les bulles, les sept régions du monde,
comment elles évoluent jusqu’en 2015 dans nos observations empiriques
par rapport au PIB par habitant,
ce qui donne ces tendances universelles convergentes
nous permettant de créer des régressions
et faire des simulations dans le futur,
pour chaque année jusqu’en 2050,
et montrer la capacité d’atteindre les ODD.
Cela nous a donné l'opportunité d'établir plusieurs scénarios
et valider différents futurs possibles :
statu quo, transformations mondiales,
projets d’investissement en entreprises, options de gouvernance,
politiques et finances afin d’explorer
notre capacité future à atteindre les ODD
dans les limites planétaires.
Les résultats nous ont surpris.
C'est la première fois qu'on montre cela
et ne devrait même pas être référencé en dehors d'ici.
La capacité est indiquée le long de deux axes.
L’axe Y montre notre capacité à rester dans les limites planétaires.
Plus on monte, plus on approche l'espace fonctionnel sûr.
Sur l'axe X, on voit les ODD.
Plus vers la droite signifie plus d'ODD atteints.
Nous voulons tous être au coin supérieur droit,
dans un monde sûr et juste dans le futur.
Le point que vous voyez ici indique les années 80.
On était dans une situation d'espace fonctionnel sûr,
mais on n'atteignait pas autant d’ODD.
Voici la tendance jusqu’en 2015.
Ici, c'est le monde conventionnel,
qui arrive à atteindre un nombre croissant d’ODD,
sortant des millions de gens de la pauvreté,
mais aux dépens de l'espace fonctionnel sûr sur terre.
Ici, c'est le scénario du statu quo dans le futur.
Si nous continuons comme aujourd’hui,
nous serons capables d'atteindre certains des ODD,
mais aux dépens de la stabilité du système terrestre.
Et si on accélère la croissance économique,
augmente la croissance du revenu annuel par 1 %
ou même triple l’économie mondiale d’ici 2050 ?
Cela nous donnerait la trajectoire suivante.
Nous irons plus loin par rapport à l'atteinte des ODD,
mais c'est au risque de déstabiliser la planète.
Et si nous accélérons encore plus ?
Et si nous augmentons notre capacité par rapport à nos promesses de 30 %
dans tous les secteurs de la société,
du climat aux accords commerciaux ?
Un scénario plus dur conviendrait un peu mieux,
mais nous pourrions échouer sur le plan d’ODD,
sans créer un espace fonctionnel sûr pour l'humanité.
C’est une conclusion décevante.
Avec le développement conventionnel, nous échouerons sur les plan des ODD
et dépasserons les limites planétaires.
Réfléchir de façon radicale !
Nous devons explorer un futur de perturbations transformateur
où nous commencerons à penser différemment.
Les modélisations, engagements et dialogues nous ont permis de définir
cinq transformations qui nous mèneraient peut-être à la réussite.
La première : réduire les émissions de moitié chaque décennie
selon la voie scientifique tracée à Paris,
en doublant l’investissement en énergie renouvelable,
créant une démocratie énergétique mondiale,
ce qui permettra d'atteindre plusieurs des ODD.
La deuxième : virer rapidement vers des systèmes d'alimentation durables,
en investissant 1 % par an dans l'intensification durable,
mettant en œuvre de solutions
déjà disponibles maintenant.
La troisième : modifier notre paradigme de développement
et apprendre des pays en développement
dont les progrès sont rapides.
Et si nous connaissons une croissance comme la Chine,
tout en la réalisant selon les paramètres environnementaux
d’une civilisation écologique ?
La quatrième : redistribuer la richesse.
Et si nous pouvons convenir que les 10 % des plus riches
ne pourraient accumuler qu'un maximum de 40 %
des revenus nationaux,
menant à une redistribution de richesse
et réformant la capacité d’équité entre les régions ?
La cinquième : améliorer l'accès au travail et à la contraception,
la santé et l'éducation,
en investissant plus dans les femmes à travers le monde,
ce qui permettra l'atteinte des ODD relatifs au genre, à l'inégalité,
à l'économie et au développement urbain.
Si nous travaillons fort sur tous ces cinq points -
nous les avons validés - ils nous feront connaître un parcours incroyable,
vers un espace opérationnel sûr et juste sur terre.
Cela montre qu'un modèle de systèmes dynamiques complexes conservateur
fondé sur la recherche empirique
peut nous permettre de penser à des transformations,
pour les 12 années à venir et au-delà,
qui nous mèneraient vers l’espace opérationnel sûr
et l’atteinte d’ambitieux objectifs sociaux et économiques.
C’est plutôt motivant,
malgré le fait que nous ne suivons pas cette trajectoire.
En résumé : après trois ans
de travail pour atteindre les ODD,
nous devons tirer un trait
et conclure que nous n'avons pas tenu nos promesses,
en plus d'aggraver la situation
pour les générations futures,
en raison du risque de franchissement des points de basculement.
En fait, nous sommes confrontés au risque de l'effet de serre,
ce qui entraînera des instabilités géopolitiques
qui pourraient rendre la vie encore plus dure
pour des milliards de personnes sur Terre.
En toute honnêteté, cela me fait vraiment peur.
C’est pour cela que je suis ici ce soir,
parce que la porte du succès est encore ouverte.
Le système terrestre est encore résilient.
Il fournit toujours des services et fonctions écosystémiques,
qui permettraient une transition vers un espace opérationnel sûr.
Nous devons penser de façon radicalement différente
et voir cela comme une prise de conscience
et une opportunité de changement transformateur,
pour changer de vitesse
et considérer les ODD comme programme de transformation
dans un espace opérationnel sûr sur terre.
Autrement dit, nous pouvons construire un monde sûr et juste.
Mais nous devons nous y mettre résolument.
Allons, lançons-nous. Merci.
(Applaudissements)